vamos a realizar algunos ejercicios con
pictogramas y nuevamente estoy
utilizando la sección de ejercicios de
khan academy aquí nos preguntan qué
árbol o árboles tiene o tienen menos de
50 manzanas elige todas las opciones
correctas aquí nos indican que este
símbolo de la manzana significa que es
igual a 10 manzanas así que vamos a
buscar aquellos árboles que tienen menos
de 5 símbolos de manzanas veamos el
pictograma tenemos aquí estos árboles
aquí vamos a contar los símbolos
recordemos que cada uno simboliza 10
manzanas este árbol tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
símbolos de manzana por lo que son 70
manzanas y nos preguntan árboles que
tengan menos de 50 este árbol no es ese
siguiente árbol tiene 1 2 3 4 símbolos o
pictogramas cada uno representa 10
manzanas por lo que tiene 40 manzanas
este árbol si aplica porque tiene menos
de 50 este tiene un 1 2 3 4 5 6 60
manzanas no lo voy a usar este tiene 1 2
3 4 pictogramas 40 manzanas este si
sirve el árbol ve y el árbol de si me
aplican y finalmente el árbol que tiene
1 2 3 30 manzanas así que los árboles b
d y e son los que voy a poner como
opciones aquí así que es el árbol b d i
vamos a revisar nuestras respuestas
es correcto veamos la siguiente pregunta
qué ardilla o ardillas se comió comieron
más de 12 bellotas elige todas las
opciones correctas aquí están los
nombres de las ardillas y nos dicen que
este símbolo de una bellota es igual a
tres bellotas comidas vamos a ver
nuestro pictograma bueno ya que cada
símbolo de bellotas son tres bellotas
comidas vamos a ver si comió 3 6 9 12 15
bellotas nos preguntan por aquellas
ardillas que comieron menos de 12
bellotas así que no he comido más de 12
veamos a extraer tres bellotas seis
bellotas nueve bellotas stripes comió
menos de doce bellotas flushing comió
tres
9 12 pues copio justamente 12 creo que
también aplica es camper comió 3
9 12 15 18 bellotas fue el que más comió
sin duda come mucho más que 12 bellotas
vamos a elegir entonces a strike y
afloje extraer y flo fin y vamos a
comprobar nuestra respuesta es correcta
veamos otra pregunta
a foot vendió no sabemos cuántos
plátanos menos que cruzaron el martes
este símbolo nos indica que equivale a 5
plátanos tenemos que ver cuánto vendió
menos fast food que gross evitar veamos
aquí está fast food y aquí está grosor y
tan grosero y town vendió 123
pictogramas más que fast food y quedamos
que cada uno de estos símbolos equivale
a 5 plátanos así que 3 por 53 símbolos
de plátanos por 5 plátanos que equivale
cada uno son 15 fast food vendió 15
plátanos menos que gross editaron el
martes comprobamos respuesta
es correcta